my name is Rachel nice
[Applause]
so guys big day for you so explain to me
the journey for years it's been like
it's been ten months that we in these
persona energies ever lucky oh yes of
course
well pedasi Mohanji suka huh he won they
wouldn't mind I know every monk couldn't
take it
Trager Hospital Jagermeister Luca okay
tweeted energy a very good energy and
I've heard that jen has said that the
collaboration that he'd like to have is
with Brad Pitt oh yes so what message is
didn't want to send out to Brad Pitt
right now during curry he understand he
will get hours or a single nanana heavy
tension backup system Mita its Wow be
confident me you got it got it
yeah no you and then Jen you can let us
know when the dream collaboration
happens because of course we're gonna
have to interview you guys is the best
bread and yeah awesome said you guys are
gonna be on carpool karaoke with James
Corden oh yeah oh yeah
who is that just incredibly exciting for
you to experience and how long did that
tape in last it took like three four
hours
really yeah total and I've heard that
it's like the biggest car they ever
rented yeah because we were seven so
what kind of car was it like some fan
but really hot yeah beside come out of a
butt cheek ours I like 16 cameras inside
and the quota was not really driving it
he like we I didn't know that I I think
I thought he really
oh yeah safety first safety first exact
of course you guys have so many fans
you've got the BTS army a lot of them
reach out to you on social media how
often are you engaging with them and
reading their messages yeah do you spend
a lot of time yes he was little xx
thinking on the Pulsar inhale exhale
natural yeah totally yep it's just part
of you this part of us I love it
all right so what's one word you would
use to describe your next tour because
you've got a 37 city tour right
sensation oh wow
that's a good one I like it okay so at
SIA she's on this album what was the
experience like collaborating with her
you know collaborative others shim every
single go to you know artists were
collaborated on E
and they wanted to Oh bother Shia on
Carrodus I don't know she go oh she gets
him I just know I tweeted about her like
six years ago
um when chandelier was first released I
just watched the movie like on the day
when its releasing like I was like
shocked I never knew about her before
but I like I watched the movie I watched
the music video and all you I got
shocked they're like these are just got
to go to like middle number one I
tweeted about that and yeah but then
collaboration happens so you know we got
a live law no one knows about the life
well you guys were just destined to
collaborate together you know maybe I
think so we've kind of spoke it into
existence that's awesome what is your
your favorite part of this album seven
mmm
what are you most proud of about this
album eternal Iran inconvenient day okay
kisses you don't buddy that was a name
yeah all they said when media we don't
mind all day
come on you know Sandow the Chandra from
Katya
congratulations guys and it's been so
fun watching your journey and your star
rise so congrats and have fun thank you
[Music]